hey this is sarah with
registerednessrn.com and today i want to
talk to you about how to put on sterile
gloves
as a nurse you will be required to use
sterile gloves when you insert foley
catheters when you access sub-q ports or
when you change central line dressings
now whenever i was a nursing student i
actually was tested on how to put on
these gloves so if you're a nursing
student you may be tested by your
clinical instructor on how to put them
on and you can use this video as a quick
reference on how to put them on
so first what we're going to do is
you'll get your sterile gloves sterile
gloves come in different sizes so be
sure to pick the correct size of sterile
gloves if you're a man you'll probably
need larger gloves they come in small
medium or large or they're labeled with
a number and these are size six they're
on the smaller side because i have small
hands so i'm going to use these
so first what you'll do is you'll open
up your sterile gloves
and before you put on your gloves of
course you'll want to do hand hygiene
either wash your hands with soap and
water or use the alcohol sanitizer
now
when if you're inserting a foley
catheter or you're going to change a
central line dressing it'll come in a
package like this okay it won't have
this width it'll become like that so
what you'll do is you'll unfold it and
when you unfold it you will see these
little creases around here this is for
you
to open them
without contaminating the gloves so what
i like to do is i like to take my
fingers and i like to reach underneath
and grab these little flaps right here
so i can pull them open and remember you
have two inches to grab
so you won't contaminate the field
and i'm pulling them open and see how
it's wanting to close like that that's
okay that's normal it happens so just
pull it out you have the two inches
remember
and flatten it out
and you have your gloves you have your
left glove and your right glove
first thing you want to do is you'll
want to glove your dominant hand i'm
right-handed so i'm going to glug my
right hand first and if you're
left-handed you'll glove your left hand
first
so what i'll do is i'll get my left hand
ready to glove my right hand
okay what i'll do is i'll take my
fingers and i'm going to grasp this cuff
right here they'll be folded like that
in the little plastic thing and grab
them
like that and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to keep my thumb tucked in
because this will allow me to slide the
glove on a lot easier without my thumb
getting in the way and if your thumb
gets in the way you may touch the
outside of the glove and contaminate it
so keep it tucked in just going to grab
and you're just going to take your hand
down in the glove
just pull it up and i'm pulling with
this and it's okay to do that
and i've pulled it up my arm and i'm
sterile hands are sterile
and take your fingers with the little
cuff and just pull it up your arm make
them fit a little bit better
okay this hand is sterile do not touch
anything other than this glove and the
inside of the surface because you will
contaminate your gloves don't touch the
bedside table your face your skin or
anything
so now we're going to glove our left
hand i'm going to take our right hand
and we're going to go underneath this
cuff instead of grasping like we did
before we're going to go underneath
it okay
and whenever you do that the paper tends
to move so just take your time
just sort of work your fingers
underneath there
and you're gonna hold it okay because we
have went underneath here and we're not
grasping like we did before and to help
us to put it on better we're going to
keep our thumb out remember how before i
told you to tuck it in we're going to
keep it out first and we're going to
keep our fingers together and we're
going to slide the glove up through
those fingers okay
like this and you're pushing with the
other hand
now we're going to tuck the thumb under
so we can slide the glove
and just pull
okay
and then it's on
and sometimes the gloves will be a
little twisted or messed up you can just
take your hands and you can just fix
them and make them more comfortable for
you
okay and we have our sterile gloves on
okay and usually what happens whenever
you are all sterile and you have your
gloves on your face will itch or the
patient will need something so do not
touch your face don't touch the bedside
table don't touch the bed
don't touch anything because if you do
you'll have to repeat this whole
procedure over again and put your
sterile gloves on
so i hope this video helped you out if
you like this video please subscribe to
my youtube channel and share this video
with your friends also visit my website
registernursern.com
for more information on nursing school
and how to succeed as a nurse thank you
so much for watching